Speaker 1: You know, usually when I say,
hey, here's what the right is saying,
and here's why it doesn't make sense because it
could happen and B could happen. A and B don't
usually happen within like a few days. But
with the entire definition of a woman thing,
it has now happened with Republican Senator Josh
Hawley. And we're going to look at it because it's
exactly why I said the idea that it's so simple to
define woman as far as Republicans are concerned
really isn't borne out by the actual fact. So
let's backtrack a little bit. When Judge Katju
Brown Jackson's confirmation hearings were going
on, Senator Marsha Blackburn, a Republican, said,
Can you define a woman? And Judge Jackson said,
You know, in the context of legality, I really
can't, because when we figure out if the question
is who can bring a gender discrimination lawsuit,
it depends on the specific facts of a case, so
I can't really tell you. And then she went on to
say, I'm also not a biologist, so I can't give
you like a biological definition. I'm a judge.
And one of the things I said to you guys was, it's
not as simple as it seems. And within a few days,
I appeared on the right wing Michael Knowles
show, and he suggested the definition for a woman,
anyone who's not a man. And of course, that
doesn't really work. It ignores intersex people.
And then he said, Well, it's a human that
produces eggs. Well, there's lots of conditions
like hormonal imbalances and thyroid conditions
and things in the womb and pituitary tumors,
which prevent women from producing
eggs. But they're still women.
And then there was well capable of reproduction
through pregnancy. Lots of conditions inhibit
reproduction. What about post-menopausal woman?
What about a postmenopausal woman? What about a
woman who has had a hysterectomy? Well, by his?
By that definition, they wouldn't be a woman.
This brings us to Republican Senator Josh Hawley,
who was recently asked about this. And in fact,
HuffPost asked a bunch of Republican senators,
Can you define woman in? Most of them didn't
even answer, probably because they realized,
even though we pretended it was really easy
for Judge Jackson to answer. We're not
answering either. But Josh Josh Hawley did,
to his credit. And Josh Hawley initially
said someone who can give birth to a child,
a mother is a woman. Someone who has a uterus is
a woman. It doesn't seem that complicated to me.
And so the follow up was What if a woman has her
uterus removed by a hysterectomy? Is she still a
woman? And Josh Hawley initially said, Yeah, well,
I don't know. Would they? And the answer was yes.
And later, when Josh Hawley was asked, Well,
would you consider a woman to be a woman if
she lost her reproductive organs to cancer? Hawley
said, I mean, a woman still has a vagina, right?
Which is a different definition. First, it was
capable of reproduction. Then it was like, Well,
actually, that's not the definition. It's having a
vagina. And then, of course, there are trans women
who have vaginas. He wasn't asked about that, but
the point here is these definitions don't work
in figuring out. Who is a woman for specific
purposes, right? If the question is, who is a
woman for needing OB-GYN care? Well, there are
definitely some transwomen that don't need an
OB-GYN. But then there's a different question who
is a woman for the purposes of bringing a gender
discrimination lawsuit? And that's a different
definition. So the most important takeaway is
they want everybody else to think
there's one definition for all contexts,
and it's really simple. And anyone who doesn't
give you that definition is being dishonest or
they're being unrealistic or whatever. And
even Josh Hawley's definition that came from
him already ran into a bunch of problems needing
him to backpedal. So if we need any reminder that
it's not as simple as they make it out to be, we
now have as a data point that Josh Hawley himself,
who was on those confirmation hearings for Judge
Jackson, although he didn't ask these particular
questions. He's already had to revise his
definition. Very interesting data point.